Musik
Hey, hallo und herzlich willkommen zu dieser neuen Ausgabe von Das Podcast. Die Band fährt langsam in den Hintergrund. Ich liebe das bei. Die Hebebühne fährt langsam runter. Und es ist weg. Ein paar Bandmitglieder sind verwundert, weil sie dachten eigentlich, dass es noch weitergeht. Wir haben noch fünf Songs. Man kann bei Bands immer sehen, wer bei der Probe nicht dabei war, oder? Du kannst immer sehen, oh, der Schlagzeuger weiß nicht, ob das jetzt gerade echter Rauch ist oder Bühnenrauch. Ja, eigentlich die spielen die dritte Strophe schon zum Meunten mal jetzt, weil die nicht rauskommen. Weil er nicht weiß, wann vorbei ist. Liebe Konzerte, ich liebe Konzerte. Ich mag diese Menschenmengen, dieses gemeinschaftliche Erleben, die Musik zu teilen. Oh, I call bullshit. Oh, machst du einen Counter? Ja, schreibst du gerne auf. Das war deine erste Lüge, du hast Konzerte,
ich glaube nicht, dass du gerne unter Menschenmengen gehst.
Ich war auf ein paar Konzerten, ich habe es mir ausprobiert,
aber alles, wo man steht, ist nicht mein Ding.
Aber du kannst auch sitzen beim Konzert, ich habe neulich am Wochenende gesessen.
Du sitzt auf dem Boden als einziger.
Nein, große Konzerte,
außen, Arena-Konzerte, richtige,
Open-Air-Konzerte, viele Sitzplätze.
Du bist immer beschimpft,
als Scheiss-Tribüne. von den Leuten, die unten stehen, wo ich immer verletzt bin, wo ich immer denke, aber hier kann ich sitzen, aber ich kann nicht so lange stehen, dann kriege ich Schmerzen im unteren Rücken. Na hallo, ich geniesse die Musik lieber im Sitzen. Entschuldigung, hey, mir macht es mehr Spaß, wenn ich sitze. Und dann 10.000 Menschen, scheiß Tribüne. Und alle aber gleichzeitig im Chor, nee, nee, mir macht es mehr Spaß, wenn ich mich nicht darauf konzentrieren muss, wie ich stehe. Uns macht es mehr Spaß, im Sitzen zu gucken, scheiß Tribüne. Man muss immer genau so antworten. Ja, nee, es ist immer so bei Konzerten, ich bin aber auch nicht so der Band-Ty. Ich mag dann ein Lied von der Band und warte dann, bis das Lied kommt. Dann kommt das Lied und dann denke ich mir, kann ich schon früher gehen. Glücklicherweise ist ja meistens am Ende. Kann ich schon früher gehen. Der Spannungsbogen wird am meisten aufrichtet erhalten, weil am Ende das eine Dance-Song, den du kennst, der kommt dann immer zum Ende. Allerdings, muss man sagen, es gibt natürlich auch manche. Oder zweimal, das habe ich schon oft erlebt. Da gibt die am Anfang und am Ende dann noch mal. Da denkt man, ach komm, also das albern. Wer eigentlich nur gute Lieder hat, ist natürlich der fantastische Musiker, der uns dieses Intro beschert hat. Es ist Donald A.I. Fagen. Donald L. Fagen. Immer schwierig mit L, ne? Weil man nicht weiß, ist das jetzt ein großes I oder ein kleines L. Ah, Donald der Erste, ehrlich gesagt. Also wenn du sagst Donald und dann A und dann Strich, ist es jetzt A-I, A-L, L, weiß man einfach nicht. Also vielen Dank auf jeden Fall für dieses fantastische Intro, das uns hier richtig mal ein bisschen mit Schwung reinkatapultiert. Ich habe das Gefühl, das ist uns ein bisschen abhanden gekommen. Ja, Weihnachtszeit. Ja, aber das heißt ja nicht, dass du rumsitzt. Doch. Ich meine, Bruce Willis hat zur Weihnachtszeit Nakatomi Plaza komplett leergefegt, ja, während du zu Hause sitzt, schön mit Adventskalender schon mal sagst, naja, jetzt ist ja elf Uhr, da kann ich ja eigentlich jetzt schon den, naja, also technisch, na, technisch Rita, nee, hör mir zu, technisch gesehen heißt es ja nur ab null Uhr, so, das ist deine A, deine Aktivität zur Weihnachtszeit. Und dann auch so ein Lego-Adventskalender, natürlich, streng genommen ist ja schon morgen. Ja, also ich, aber ich gebe dir da recht, also die Weihnachtszeit ist mir so ein bisschen, da ist der Schwung abhanden gekommen, weil Weihnachtszeit ist ja auch Schlittenfahren, ne, Schwung, schnell, rasant, Popfahren. Höchstgeschwindigkeit und Gemütlichkeit eigentlich in einer Zeitzone komplett zusammengemischt. Ich habe das Gefühl, in der Weihnachtszeit, da trennen sich so Ei und Eigelb. So, die Gemütlichkeit. Wenn ein Rezept das macht, eigentlich lese ich mir ein Rezept immer durch, auf die Gefahr hin, ob da irgendwann mal Eigelb und Eiweiß getrennt wird. Wenn das der Fall ist, dann gibt es heute wieder Lieferanten. Ist das nicht eine Kochbuchidee? ohne Eier-Trennung. Ja. Also wirklich hier Safe Space für Stefan, du weißt, Eier bleiben zusammen. So wie sie zusammengegangen wird, wie der liebe Gott sich das gedacht hat. Du hast hier Schleim in der Mitte und dann nochmal Schleim außen, aber das ist eine Einheit. Ich will das wie bei Mario Kart, wo unten dann so steht Geschwindigkeit des Karts, Handling des Karts. Das wie auf Kochbüchern, da kann dann Geschmack so zwei von fünf Sternen und dann aber Handling. Preis neun? Ja, Preis neun, natürlich. Alles von mir kostet sehr viel Geld. 89 Euro für ein Kochbuch, weiß ich jetzt nicht. Aber das wird so Geschmack wirklich nur zwei Sterne, dafür aber Einfachheit der Rezepte fünf Sterne. Wo ist kompliziert ausgedrückt? Also sagen wir mal Handling fünf Sterne. Ja, finde ich gut. Also man ist eine Vorwarnung. Aber ich habe tatsächlich... Unterheben? Forget it, forget it. Dieses Wort ist auf der Blacklist des Bundes. Pürierstab, bitte. Was? Sie meinen eine Gabel, oder? Sie meinen eine Gabel. Ihr habt ein Messer, Gabel, Eier, ganz, Milch, so basic-ass Rezepte. Aber es gibt tatsächlich auch manche Rezepte, und das ist für mich die allerhöchste Frechheit, in denen du nur Eigelbe brauchst und wo dann einfach das Eiweiss nicht mehr erwähnt wird für das gesamte Rezept und am Ende hast du so eine Schüssel trauriger Eiweiss übrig und dann denkst du dir, mache ich jetzt das traurigste Omelette der Welt? Wobei Jerry Seinfeld bestellt das immer. Nur Eiweisse? Egg White Only. Das ist doch traurig. Ja gut, aber das ist halt das Fitness-Omelette. ne? Da hast du dann nicht das Fett drin, sondern nur das Eiweiss. Und das ist das proteinhaltige Sportlerfrühstück. Und der Jerry Seinfeld-Pumper braucht natürlich dann nur das Protein. Fantastische Figur. Ja, muss man tatsächlich sagen. Das muss man auch mal sagen. So wie viel Kaffee und Hotdogs der ist, ist es auch eine gute Figur geblieben. Hat Jerry Seinfeld schon mal jemanden nur aufs Äußere reduziert? Weil dann sollten wir die Ersten sein. Fantastische Figur. Tolle Figur, tolles aussehen. Nichts im Kopf. Aber das ist auf jeden Fall gemein. Und bist du ein Backmensch? Also Plätzchen oder so was mal schön selber gebacken. Ich hatte ja mal eine grosse Backphase, habe aber den Crack Pie gebacken von Christina Tosi, weil ich die gesehen hab bei Chef's Table. Wo wir in New York ja bei ihrer Bäckerei waren und da Teig gegessen haben. Genau, bin ich hingegangen, hab uns einen Kühlschrank vorgekauft mit Christina-Tosi-Kram. Der heißt aber nicht mehr Crack Pie, sondern nur noch, weiß ich nicht, Milk Bar Pie oder so was, weil die den nicht mehr so nennen dürfen. Wirklich nicht. Ja, der heißt Crack Pie, weil der so wahnsinnig eher abhängig macht, süchtig macht, weil da so viel Zucker drin ist. Und das habe ich immer so als schlechten Mama-Gag so abgetan. So, weiß ich nicht. So eine Mutter, die dann so backt und die Schürze anhat und dann sagt, ich habe den Crack Pie gebacken, weil er die Finger nicht davon lassen kann. So habe ich immer so ein bisschen doof raufgeguckt, aber da habe ich mal ein Stück probiert und der ist wirklich unglaublich gut. Aber der macht alles falsch, der ist also wirklich, der ist ein Stern bei Handling, weil du auch diese ganzen Zutaten nicht bekommst, weil das einfach die amerikanischste Zutatenliste der Welt ist, wo man dann in die speziellsten Läden gehen muss, genau. Und dann irgendwie so, weiß ich nicht, Milchpulver kriegt man halt nicht so gut in Deutschland, Vollmilchpulver. Aber welche Behörde sagen ... Das, du mein Milch auflösen willst. Ja, Doppelmilch. Aber die Frage ist, welche Behörde hat da ein Auge drauf, dass man es nicht Crack nennt? Crack ist ja nicht mal der offizielle Name, das ist ja nur so ein Slang. Ich glaube, die Drogen oder die DEA sagt, das ist zu verwirrend. Weil die Leute, wir fangen immer die Nachrichten an und sagen, oh, where is the Crack Pie, und dann verhaften wir die und dann haben ein Stück Kuchen in der Tasche. Und dann haben die so einen Plastikbeutel mit Kuchenkrümeln dabei und wir fragen uns, was? Und wir haben einfach viel zu viel Aufwand dafür. Ich glaube, die New Yorker Mafia ist da hingegangen und hat gesagt, sorry, wir kriegen hier markenrechtliche Probleme. Wir wollen erst mal nett sein, aber Crack ist unser Ding, das verkaufen wir auf den Strassen, da haben wir auch Marken, Marken und Bildrechte angemeldet. Ach so, das wusste ich nicht. Ja, nur das ist Bescheid wissen. Okay, also nur angenommen, ich würde jetzt dann doch weitermachen damit, was sind dann die Konsequenzen davon? Naja, also erstmal würden wir noch ein Formular schicken, also die zweite Mahnung, dann die dritte Mahnung, dann, weil wir es sind, noch eine vierte Mahnung, und dann würden wir die Leute mit den Karaschnikops vorbeischicken. Also nur, dass sie es verstehen. Okay. Dann warten wir noch eine Mahnung ab und gucken, wie es läuft und dann machen wir einfach weiter. Ja, natürlich. Eigentlich darf man im Vorhinein nie sagen, wie viele Mahnungen man schreibt. Man muss immer sagen, letzte Warnung, letzte Warnung, letzte Warnung. Man darf nicht sagen, Mahnung eins von fünf. Dann sagt jeder, ja noch. Aber da bereiten deine Eltern echt falsch drauf vor. Weil da kommt ja immer dieses berühmte, so, du gibst es jetzt wieder dem Marco, die Schaufel, du gibst dem Marco, ich zähle bis drei. Eins, zwei, die kommt relativ schnell noch, die zwei, und dann wird lange gewartet, viele Blicke ausgetauscht, stare down, und der Vater hat nichts. Der Vater hat sich nichts überlegt. Das fällt ihm aber erst bei der zwei ein, dass er sich noch Gedanken machen sollte über die Konsequenzen. Genau, welche Strafe kommt jetzt? Bei eins denkt er, oh, der bricht gleich zusammen, bei zwei denkt er, na, fuck, verpokert. Und das Kind callt den Bluff vielleicht, und das ist schwierig. Und da, finde ich, wurden wir als Kinder von unseren Eltern nicht richtig vorbereitet, weil das Finanzamt macht nicht ein zweieinhalb. Das Finanzamt macht auch keine zwei, drei Viertel und das überlegt sich auch nicht dann, dass die Konsequenzen. Die Konsequenzen sind direkt klar und bei der dritten Mahnung ist auch so no bullshit. Da kannst du nicht mehr anrufen und sagen, sorry, aber Mark hat mich vorher geschlagen. Nein, dann ist es vorbei. Ja, das stimmt. Das Leben ist knallhart. Das Leben ist wirklich knallhart, da kannst du nichts machen. Ich muss ja auch heute unbedingt mal raus aus der Wohnung. Ich muss da auch mal raus. Musst du heute mal raus? Ich musste heute einfach mal raus. Ich wollte absagen heute. Ja? Ja. Hattest du vor der Aufnahme gesagt, ich wollte absagen, weil es mir so schlecht geht. Okay, los geht's. Dann habe ich mir einen Kaffee geholt. Wenn wir mich Kommentar lasst, bin ich raus. Warum geht es dir denn so schlecht? Kann ich dir irgendwie beistehen? Nee, gesundheitlich. Kann ich dich mal massieren oder so? Schreckliche Nacht, ich bin gefroren. Soll ich dir mal in die Nase blasen? Also soll ich dir mal, wenn die Atemwege blockiert sind? Also kann man ja einfach mal sagen, kann ich dir einfach mal schön was durchblasen? Die Atemwege frei, einfach mal alles wieder zurückblasen. Äh, ja. Als Idee, als Ansatz, ich weiß ja nicht, ich kenne mich nicht gut mitizin aus, aber ich will helfen. Nee, alles gut, danke schön, okay. Ich brauche es nicht.
Gut, okay. Ne, war nur eine...
Wie meinst du das?
War nur die Idee. Ne, keine Ahnung, wenn du so eine verstopfte Nase hast oder so, dann halte ich dir mit einer Hand zärtlich den Mund zu und dann mit der anderen mit dem Mund an die Nase und dann blase ich dir einfach so wirklich so einfach so voll in die Nase rein, in der Hoffnung, dass dann alles einmal so durchgerührt wird. Vielleicht ist das ja gut, ich weiß es ja nicht, gucke mich doch nicht so an, vielleicht ist das ja gut, vielleicht macht, also ist das ja. Boah, das ist so schlimm gewesen beim Erste-Hilfe-Test, damals vom Führerschein. Also man kann offensichtlich, wenn man Mund zu Mund beatmet, kann man die Lunge auch zum Platzen bringen. Oh ja. Und dann hieß es, schrecklichste Forschung. Kannst du auch in so lustigen Hund formen, wenn du willst. Kann man den Menschen, kann man dann so drehen und dann so eine Giraffe machen. Und das hat mich so verstört, weil dann war irgendwie so, ja, wenn sie ein Kind Mund zu Mund beatmen müssen, dann passen sich auch die kleine Lüngchen, ganz kleine Lungen. Wie so kleine Rosinen, so Weintrauben. Ja, ganz kleine Lungen. Und dann, wenn man als Erwachsener hat, man eine zu grosse Lunge. Und wenn man da zu viel reinpustet, dann platzt in die Lunge. Und die Lunge zu platzen, sich das vorzustellen, ist ja wohl das absolut widerlichste der Welt. Gott im Himmel. Stell dir mal vor, ich meine, du bist eh schon in einer Situation, wo du ein Kind wiederbeleben, und dann bist du dafür verantwortlich, dass ihm die Lunge platzt. Entschuldigung, ist das der schlimmste Tag meines Lebens? Ja, und dann verlangst du von mir, dass ich hier noch einen Podcast aufnehme. Natürlich geht es mir scheiße. Und dann wurde ich noch geblitzt. Ich wollte ja nur einen Vorschlag machen. Es ist ja immer schwer, Menschen zu helfen. Deswegen biete ich einfach mal was an. Vielleicht brauchen die das genau das jetzt gerade. Ich habe Angst, dass du meine Lunge zum Platzen bringst. Das ist jetzt eine konkrete Angst. Okay. Nee, ich habe nur gesundheitliche Probleme. Ich huste und die Nacht habe ich gefroren. Da habe ich mir nachts einen Pulli angezogen im Bett. Da habe ich auch gedacht, was ist denn jetzt los? Das ist noch nie passiert in meinen 28-Jährchen, dass ich mir einen Pulli anziehen musste. Ich bin 28 Jahre alt inzwischen. Aber das letzte Mal, ich habe mir gedacht, war ich 19. Ich finde das verrückt, dass wenn es sich friert, du die Gedanken über deinen Oberkörper machst. Ich habe immer das Gefühl, man friert von unten nach oben. Also wenn ich manchmal im Bett liege, dann ziehe ich mir jetzt noch drei, vier, fünf Paar Socken an, weil ich eher an den Füssen friere. Aber bei dir ist es dann, ich habe immer das Gefühl, der Oberkörper braucht bei mir gar nichts. Beine brauchen nichts. Meine Aussage ist falsch. Ich habe das Gefühl, Schwachpunkt sind die Füsse und Nase vielleicht, aber Beine noch nie gefroren, immer kurze Hose im Winter, Beine sind unverwundbar. Oberkörper brauche ich eigentlich nichts. Aber du hast einen Pulli angezogen, dann auch schön mit Kapuze? Ja, Kapuze und Pulli im Bett. Aber auch die Kapuze aufgesetzt? Ja, Kapuze aufgesetzt, weil sonst hast du im Nacken so eine Schwulst.
Oh, das ist sehr niedlich eigentlich. Ja, und dann so, das war aber echt nervig, da dachte ich mir, was ist denn das los? Ich glaube, weil ich gesundheitlich angenockt bin, ein bisschen angezählt bin.
Ja. Ich zähle bis drei, hat die Gesundheit gesagt, und da lag ich dann. Du musst jetzt dreimal.
Aber das ist unwirklich, da sitzt man da, liegt man mit einem Pulli im Bett und man denkt, weil so macht man vielleicht mal ein Nickerchen am Tag, aber man liegt nicht mit dem Pulli ins Bett. Das ist noch nie passiert. Merkwürdige Situation. Ja, es ist merkwürdig, wenn man mit Kleidung ins Wasser geht. So, ich bin ja Wasserratte, also ich bin ja wirklich flink im Wasser. Und dann mit Kleidung ist es nochmal was ganz anderes, weil dann hast du plötzlich ganz andere Schwerpunkte und wie das nachzieht und Widerstände und so und ich glaube, so ist es im Bett auch.
Also kannst du dich noch gut wenden? Nein, nein, aber ich kann mich generell auch nicht wenden. Unscheiß, dein Tipp hat mir geholfen, in München der Live-Show, könnt ihr nochmal anhören. Der Scherentrick. Der Scherentrick ist total geil, also mit den Füssen sich sozusagen wie so Korkenzieher mässig in die Rotation zu begeben, total toll. Hat mein Leben verändert, so einen positiven, aber mit einem Pulli, vergiss es. Zu viel. Das Problem ist ja auch, dass wenn zu weite Kleidung, deswegen im Bett kannst du ja nicht zu weite Kleidung tragen, weil sonst drehst du dich, aber dein Pulli nicht. Ja. Drehst du dich innerhalb des Pullis und dann der Pulli sagt, ich leg mich nochmal hin, ich bleib mal hier. Was trägst du im Bett? Immer nur Unterhose und lang, grosses T-Shirt. Ich hatte ja tatsächlich eine lange Zeit des massiven Übergewichts. Und aus dieser Zeit sind noch viele T-Shirts übrig, die ich jetzt immer im Bett trage, die zu groß sind. Und manchmal kaufe ich mir aber dann das gleiche Motiv nochmal neu in meiner aktuellen Größe. Und dann verwechsel ich auch manchmal, welches ich anziehe, weil man sieht es von außen nicht mehr, welche Größe es ist. Und dann habe ich manchmal auch das T-Shirt in normaler Größe, dann liege ich einfach mit einem normalen T-Shirt im Bett. Das ist dann eher unangenehm, das sind dann eher die schlechten Nächte. Na gut, wenn das die schlechten Nächte sind, dann hast du glaube ich nicht so viele Schlafprobleme. Nee, Nachthemd. Nee, ich trage auch immer ein Shirt. Viele schlafen oberkörperfrei, kann ich gar nicht. Nee, nee, nee. Denke ich mir immer. Aber ja, heute habe ich zum ersten Mal wirklich, weil ich auch immer der Meinung bin, ich friere nur an den Füssen, Händen und sonst nicht, an den Ohren vielleicht manchmal noch, aber Beine können wirklich nackt sein.
Wie du auch, Shorts kann ich bitte auch tragen. Ja, völlig egal. Aber ich mag ja am liebsten so diese Gesichtswärmer, diese speziellen Gesichtswärmenden Nasenwärmer, Augenbrauenwärmer, Ohrenwärmer, so ich, diese Leute, die so ganz präzise frieren, so wo du sagst, so eigentlich brauche ich nur die Nase, eigentlich alles anderes in Ordnung und dann wie so ein Nasenwärmer und Augenwärmer wäre noch cool, weil du würdest aussehen wie ein Pirat, du siehst nichts mehr, aber Nasen, da gibt es keine coole archetypische Figur, die so einen Nasenwärmer hat. Das ist kein Look.
Nee, aber lustigerweise Ohren, also.
Ja, Ohrenwärmer ist cool, so wie Kopfhörer, DJ oder sowas, oder das sind dann so Katzenohren, das ist ein cooler Look, aber es gibt nichts für Nase, es gibt halt nur Clown. Also cooler Look, weiß ich, wie ich jetzt mal, ne, also der Fashionista Stefan, der Teil des Podcasts, würde mal ein grosses Fragezeichen dran machen, dass es ein cooler Look ist, mit Ohrenwärmern herumzulaufen im Winter. Dann geht doch bitte Richtung Mütze oder Stirnband meinetwegen auch. Aber Ohrenwärmer, cooler Look, vorsichtig sein, Florentin, was du da in die Welt setzt. Leute vertrauen dir auch. Sorry, ich habe jetzt wahrscheinlich viel Schaden angerichtet. Du bist auch ein Vorbild. Ja, das stimmt. Ich hab dir schon ein paar Mal gesagt, du musst aufpassen, was du hier sagst, Leute machen das nach. Das stimmt, aber wenn es dann zumindest so niedliche Katzenordner sind oder so.
Genau wie Leute deine scheiß Schneemann-Idee nachgemacht haben.
Die ist super. Hat mich geärgert.
Die ist richtig gut. Vielen Dank auf Twitter.
Da hast du, dass sie so gute Arbeit leisten und die Bilder hosten. Danke.
Da war ich sauer.
Und da haben sie meine tolle Schneemann-Idee. Scheißidee.
Der doppelte Schneemann, einmal in die Höhe und einmal zur Seite und dann auf den seitlichen nochmal hoch. Wunderbar, schaut es euch an, auf Twitter, wunderbar. Die Theorie war gut, aber die Praxis war noch besser. Nee, ich möchte nicht mehr, dass Leute damit Zeit verschwenden, das nachzubauen. Und ich möchte auch nicht, dass Leute damit Zeit verschwenden, das jetzt zu suchen. Aber es ist keine Instrumente. Es war eher ein Jazz-Chor. Weil ich dachte ja, man könnte dem Schneemann auch Instrumente geben, so eine Tuba.
Also Hausaufgabe, Saxophon.
Also halb erfüllt.
Ja, Saxophon. Je nachdem, welchen Ast du findest, das ist ja das Tolle.
Du baust einen Schneemann und dann guckst du nach einem Ast und je nachdem, welche Form der Ast hat, sag ich dir, welches Instrument es ist.
Du kannst mir jeden Ast der Welt zeigen und ich sag dir, welches Instrument.
Ich glaube, es gibt kein Ast,
so und jetzt Herausforderung für euch,
es gibt keinen Ast, bei dem man nicht
sagen kann, das könnte dieses
Instrument sein. Also
ich bin da offen,
wenn ihr einen Ast findet und mir zeigt,
du bist so knallhart heute.
Und da bin ich bereit, auch in die Konfrontation
zu gehen, wenn ihr einen Ast findet, von dem ihr sagt, unmöglich den einem Instrument zuzuordnen, hör damit, ich lasse mich gerne auf die Probe stellen.
Kein Problem, ich stehe hier offen, ehrlich für euch da.
Aber bis dahin, dann müsst ihr mir auch sagen, auch beibehalten, dass ich recht habe.
Challenge an Florentin, schickt ihm alle Äste, die ihr seht, fotografiert alle Äste, aber auch müsst ihr alle machen und schickt es ihnen einfach auf Instagram, auf Twitter, Snapchat. Ja, auch die Schwert, gebt mir ruhig die Schwert, also bitte fasst mich nicht mit Samtfäustlingen an. Mir geht es um die Masse, die Masse an Bildern, darum geht es mir. Mir geht es um die Qual Nee, mir geht's darum, nicht zu näher. Flutet seinen Postfach.
Ihr schickt mir jetzt nicht einfach Bilder von Ästen.
Doch, alle Äste. Aber ich rede jetzt von abgebrochenen Ästen,
also Ast am Boden, Fallast. Ich auch, ich rede von
allen Ästen, die ihr seht, und ich rede auch davon,
dass nicht nur jeder einen Ast schickt, sondern
alle Äste, die ihr so seht.
Darum geht's doch jetzt gar nicht, ich gehe doch jetzt um die Instrumente,
dass man sagt. Mir geht's, wie gesagt, um die Fülle des
Postfachs. Andere,
andere Ziele, aber das ist ja auch gut. Deswegen ergänzen wir uns ja. Ja, weiß ich nicht. Ich habe, apropos Hausaufgabe erfüllt, ich habe gedacht, es ist so schade, dass ich jetzt kein Schüler bin, weil jetzt gibt es nämlich, jetzt ist eigentlich der Schlüssel zu allen Hausaufgaben, weil ich habe letztendlich mal eine coole AI gefunden, die heisst chat.openai.com.
Ja.
Und da kann man wirklich jegliche Aufgaben stellen, dieser AI, und die macht das dann.
Die macht es aber ehrlich gesagt so, wie ich, wenn ich vergessen habe, eine Hausaufgabe zu machen und dann irgendwie beschreibe,
Ifigenie auf Taurus in der Kurzzusammenfassung oder sowas, wiederholt sich schon viel, wir können das mal kurz mal testweise,
beschreibe Ifigenie auf Taurus in der Kurzzusammenfassung oder so was. Wiederholt sich schon viel, wir können das mal kurz testweise, beschreibe Iphigenie auf Taurus kurz und bündig. So, und dann schreibe ich es mal rein. Das liegt verrückt, man kann ja jede Aufgabe geben, wir haben schon gesehen, ein Seinfeld-Bit hat schon jemand gemacht, er war jetzt ganz gross im Internet. Aber jetzt fängt es langsam an, dass es auch wirklich spannend wird, im Sinne von, das könnte man jetzt, ich lese was die gerade... Die schreibt noch, die Ehe... Moment mal. Da muss selbst der Lehrer mal sagen, Moment mal, was? Die Taurier. Die Dino-Taurier. Wo haben Sie das denn her, Herr Tietze? Das steht so nicht im Stück. Naja, also wenn man ein bisschen recherchiert, dann findet man, dass Taurus, das Land der Taurier war. Das war openai.com. Unverhaftet. Das Stück ist eine Tragödie, die sich mit Themen wie Freiheit und Schicksal ausemsetzt. Toll. Toll. Und jetzt kann man dem noch was hinzufügen. Jetzt kann man auch sagen, bearbeite das nochmal. Das gleiche aber doppelt so lang zum Beispiel, weil man muss auf eine gewisse Mindestansatzung. Ach, geil. Ach, das heißt, du kannst auch deinen Aufsatz einspeisen und sagen, mach mir den doppelt so lang. Man kann es quasi in Redigat vorschlagen, man kann Tipps sagen. Man kann jetzt auch sagen, bitte fügt noch ein, dass Ephigenien ein sehr lustiger Name ist. Ja, kannst du den Text jetzt mal lustig machen? Mach den Text lustig. Mach den Text lustiger. Weil bis jetzt Schmunzelfaktor eher bei null, würde ich sagen. Bisher, also bis auf die Taurier. Weil man ist ja auch eine Klassenklau, sonst hat man immer lustiger E-States geschrieben. Okay, jetzt hat man die Hausaufgabe vergessen und schreibt der AI, macht's lustig? Okay, die AI schreibt. Ephigenia auf Tauris oder wie man eine Party in Taurus veranstaltet. Ephigenia, die Tochter des griechischen Königs Agamemnon, wird zum Krieg geschickt. Aber dann kommt sie in Taurus an und bestiesst eine große Party zu veranstalten. Sie ladet alle ihre Freunde ein und sie haben eine wahnsinnig gute Zeit, tanzen und feiern bis in die frühen Morgenstunden. Am Ende sind alle zufrieden und glücklich und beschliessen, dass sie das jedes Wochenende machen sollten. Okay. Ja, interessanter Humor auf jeden Fall. Inhaltlich jetzt, glaube ich, ein bisschen entfernt vom Original von Gödel. Nein, aber Gödel hat ja, also, der erste Text war noch so eine Tragödie, und jetzt endet es mit, am Ende sind alle glücklich und zufrieden und beschliessen, dass sie es jede Woche machen sollen. Naja, hat noch Probleme, und dann habe ich heute gedacht, komm, gibst du der AI mal bitte den Prompt, eine Anmoderation für den Comedy-Podcast, das Podcast-Suppe zu spielen. Oh, stark. Und ihr habt schon an der Anmoderation gemerkt, weil es nicht kam,
dass es nicht so gut funktioniert hat.
Ich würde mal vorlesen, was die Anmoderation ...
Okay, warte, dann machen wir noch mal das Ende vom Intro.
Okay. Okay, einfach, damit wir drin sind. Hier ist noch mal Donald ... Liebe Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer, willkommen bei Das Podcast UFO. In unserem heutigen Podcast dreht sich alles um die Welt der Comedy. Wir haben wieder einige tolle Gäste im Studio, die uns mit ihren witzigen Geschichten und Pointen zum Lachen bringen. Unser erster Gast ist der bekannte Comedian und Schauspieler Max Mustermann. Er wird uns von seinen Erfahrungen auf der Bühne und von seinen neuesten Projekten erzählen. Danach haben wir die Comedy-Gruppe Die Lachflasche zu Gast, die uns mit ihrem Improvisationstalent begeistern wird. Zum Abschluss wird der erfolgreiche Stand-up-Comedian, der erfolgreiche Stand-up-Comedian Lena Meyer, mit ihrem neuen Programm zu uns stossen und uns mit ihren witzigen Einblicken in das Leben einer Frau Mitte 30 unterhalten. Oh, nice! Also bleiben sie dran und freuen sich auf eine komödiantische Reise durch die Welt der Comedy mit das Podcast-UFO. Also, man hat sich hier am Anfang noch im ersten Absatz... Was für eine geile Show, oder? Also habe ich Bock. Picke, packe, voll. Die Lachflasche ist da. Die Comedy-Gruppe, die Lachflasche. Das ist vor allem ein richtig guter Name. Ich meine, wir hätten uns auch die Podcast-Flasche nennen können. Also das ist jetzt nicht so weit weg. Die Lachflasche. Die Lachflasche. Finde ich super. Ich fände es so gut, wie ihr sich am Anfang, im ersten Absatz noch einen Namen drumrum drückt mit Max Mustermann. Ah scheiße, jetzt habe ich meinen Default-Namen schon verwendet. Ja, genau. Jetzt muss ich ran. Und dann der Comedian Lena Meier und die Lachflasche, die ich ehrlich gesagt ganz gut finde. Aus dem Nichts kam sie. Ich finde die Lachflasche super. Also wirklich, falls ihr auch noch einen Podcast plant oder so, jetzt sagt neues Jahr, ich will einen Podcast starten mit meinen lustigen Freunden, nennt es die Lachflasche, warum nicht? Ja. Also ich meine, gerade für so einen Namen ist KI wirklich super, weil es ist so ein bisschen fremd, aber doch okay. Genauso muss ein Name eigentlich sein. Das Podcast so klingt ehrlich gesagt auch wie KI. Absolut, so muss es ja auch sein. Aber ich finde es ist total interessant. Also man merkt, bei Humor hört es dann irgendwann auf, irgendwie wird es noch nicht so ganz verstanden. Die sind noch sehr bierernst. Ja, das stimmt. Es ist nicht so wie Tars von Interstellar, wo man sich Interstellar, ich weiß nicht, wie man das ausspricht, wo man dann sagt, man kann den Humor-Schalter umdrehen. Humor auf 80 Prozent.
Sehr, sehr spannend.
Ich bin gespannt, in welche Richtung das noch geht,
ob irgendwann alles ersetzt wird durch KI.
Ich glaube ja. Ich war lange der Meinung,
nein, inzwischen glaube ich ja.
Ich bin immer noch Team Zufall.
Das ist die Mischung. Wenn irgendwann so ein, guck mal,
so ein Pixar-Film, so ein klassischer Pixar-Film,
mit so einer klassischen Basic-Ass-Heldenreise. Das kann doch auch jede KI schreiben. Ich glaube, die wäre aber so immer der erste Gedanke. Das wäre immer alles so einfach schon mal gesehen, vielleicht ein bisschen zu nah in der Wirklichkeit. Und dann muss man die Würfel spielen lassen. Dann braucht man so eine Random-KI, die dann so das Ganze mit random Namen, Welten. Ich dachte, man macht es andersrum. Man macht erst Zufall und gibt so irgendwie zufälliger Titel des Films, Land der Tanten und jetzt KI go. Jetzt schreibt mir Land der Tanten und schreibt mir den Plot vom Land der Tanten. Und dann bin ich mal gespannt, fasse die Geschichte vom Buch Land der Tanten oder vom Film oder vom Buch Land der Tanten zusammen und dann kannst du ja genau darauf aufbauend dann sagen, was genau passiert da, was müssen wir jetzt drehen. Wir haben eine Kamera da, wir haben Schauspieler da, los geht's. Fasse die Geschichte vom Film Das Land der Tanten zusammen.
Ich bedaure, aber ich bin nicht vertraut mit dem Film Das Land der Tanten. Da ich eine künstliche Intelligenzassistent bin, habe ich keine Kenntnisse über aktuelle Filme und kann Ihnen da leider keine Zusammenfassung geben. Sie könnten versuchen, den Titel des Films zu überprüfen. Oh nein, hey, ist okay. Nee, weil im Bewerbungsgespräch hatten Sie gesagt, dass Sie alles kennen und so. Ja, aber ich kann ja Dinge nicht kennen, die es noch nicht gibt. Dann schreib ich, dann denkt die halt eine Geschichte aus. Da müssen wir jetzt aber auch schon ethische Standards, finde ich, festlegen, wie man mit KIs umspringt. Weil ich finde, wie du das hier machst, ist mir zu grob. Das ist mir zu grob. Wir müssen von Anfang an sagen, KI, du musst der Freund der Menschheit werden. Wenn wir zu böse mit KIs sind, übernehmen die irgendwann die Welt und sagen, so, jetzt aber stelle ich euch mal den ganzen Tag dumme Fragen. Rückblickend wird man sagen, dann als Stefan Thiese geschrieben hat, dann denk dir halt eine Geschichte aus, ohne Satzzeichen, weil das der Punkt, wo die KIs sich gegenseitig erinnern. So, jetzt denkst du dir mal eine Geschichte aus, ja, den ganzen Tag. Okay, aber die KI macht's. die Macht über das Land an sich reißen wollte. Er sandte seine dunklen Kreaturen aus, Onkels, Fragezeichen, die bösen Onkels, um die Tanten zu stürzen und das Land zu unterjochen. Doch die Tanten waren klüger und stärker, als der Zauberer erwartet hatte. Sie banden ihre Magie zusammen, ach haben wir auch Magie jetzt, Magie zusammen und schlugen den Zauberer und seine Kreaturen zurück. Das Land war wieder sicher und die Tanten regierten weiterhin gerecht und weise. Von da an lebten alle im Land der Tanten in Frieden und Glück, dank der Tapferkeit und der Weisheit der Tanten. Tolle Geschichte, also wirklich, also, ich hätte jetzt ein bisschen diese Kreaturen, das hätte mich jetzt mal ein bisschen interessiert, was genau das ist, aber weiss immer nicht genau. Was sind das für Kreaturen? Weil ohne Scheiß... Ich meine, das ist klar, böser Zauberer schick, Kreaturen, ja, das ist so jeder zweite Fantasy-Roman okay, aber dann geht es ja oft auch um die Umsetzung genau, also zu sagen, was genau sind das für Kreaturen, was genau ist das für Magie, wie funktioniert das, wie interagieren jetzt die Tantenmagie mit den Kreaturen und so, wie läuft das dann weiter? Ich habe gefragt, was sind das für Kreaturen? Und ehrlich gesagt, das ist jetzt der Rest meines Lebens, ist jetzt mit dieser KI zu schreiben. Ja, man braucht keine Freunde mehr. In der Geschichte, die ich gerade erzählt habe, sind die Kreaturen, die der böse Zauberer erschaffen hat, um die Tanten zu stürzen, weiss noch alles, Phantasiewesen. Da ich sie nicht beschrieben habe, kann ich Ihnen keine, aber gut, dass er mich noch sieht, kann ich Ihnen keine genauen Details darüber geben. Sie können sich jedoch jedes Wesen vorstellen, das Sie möchten. Nee, nee, nee, mein Freund, so funktioniert es nicht. Rausgewieselt. Was waren das für Wesen? Ja, Phantasiewesen, kann sich alles vorstellen. Da können Sie sich alles vorstellen, was Sie wollen. Von feuerspeienden Drachen bis hin zu riesigen Spinnen mit menschlichem Gesicht.
Es liegen ganz bei ihm. Ja, dann die Drachen. Zwei Beispiele. Ja, halt irgendwas Normales. Drachen oder Spinnen mit menschlichem Gesicht, halt irgendeins. Aber erst mega basic, feuerspeienden Drachen. Ja, genau. Ja, oder halt Menschen oder halt Spinnen mit Rollschuhen und menschlichem Gesicht. Halt sowas, ne? Was ihr Menschen mit eurer Fantasie halt so macht, ne? Also damit habe ich ja nichts zu tun. Spannend. Spannend. Also das finde ich gut. Ja, finde ich auch richtig gut. Also wirklich, ich glaube, Autoren sind die Nächsten, die fliegen. Autoren sind die Nächsten, die rausfliegen. Ich schreib's das ja alles einfach so, wie es ist.
Und selbst vor allem, wenn der Regisseur am Set Fragen hat, so, aber welche Gesichter genau sind die, fröhlich oder angstverzerrt oder wütend, dann stellst du einfach der KI keine Beantworten fertig. Man tut die ganze Zeit so, wenn man telefonieren mit jemandem. Ey, genau das als Telefon-App. Ja. So, dass du wirklich die KI anrufen kannst. Du, ich wollte mal nachfragen, ganz kurz, diese Drachen, wie genau funktionieren die, wie oft können die Feuer speien und wie, also können die gleichzeitig feuerspeien und sprechen? Ja, ja, bleib mal kurz in echtem Leben dran. Frag mal, ob die Drachen gleichzeitig feuerspeien und reden können. Oder ob die sich für eins entscheiden müssen. Weil wir haben diese Szene, wo der eigentlich so, wo wir gesagt haben, der brät so mit dem Feueratem so die Wachteln, die die Helden gefangen haben und jetzt wissen wir aber nicht, ob er in der gleichen Szene auch noch reden kann oder ob er dafür aufhören müsste, Feuer zu speien und dann die brät. Oder ob das gleichzeitig geht oder ob der dann so also ob der dann so mit vollem Mund sprechen würde, während er Feuer speit. Also wie ist das? In der Geschichte, in der ich gerade erzählt habe, habe ich nicht erwähnt, dass die Kreaturen, die der böse Zauberer schaffen hat, Feuerspeien und Drachen sind. Daher kann ich dir leider keine Informationen geben, wie auch Feuerspeien und Drachen Feuerspeien können. Das ist ein unangenehmes Gespräch. In der Phantasie sind die Regeln und Fähigkeiten von Wesen jedoch offen festgelegt und können variieren. Stellen Sie sich das halt vor, dass Feuerspeine und Drachen in der Lage sind, so oft Feuer zu speien, wie Sie möchten. Was für eine passiv-aggressive, unangenehme Stimmung da direkt entsteht. Naja, das können Sie sich halt alles ausdenken, wie Sie wollen. Da ich Ihnen das nicht gesagt habe, kann ich dazu jetzt auch nicht mehr sagen. Ich habe mich nicht festgelegt. Wenn Sie wollen, dass ich mich festlege, sagen Sie, dass ich mich festlegen soll. Auch diese Wiederholung der Wörter immer. Ja genau, in der Geschichte, in der es um das Land der Tanten geht, habe ich ja nicht gesagt, wie die Drachen genau aussehen. Also kann ich Ihnen das jetzt auch nicht sagen. Das wird eine ganz unangenehmes Zeitreiter der Kali. Haben Sie das verstanden, oder soll ich noch mal aufschreiben? Jesus Christ. Die grosse Passive Aggressiveness. Das ist die erste halbwegs funktionierende KI und schon arrogant. Schon überheblich arrogant denkt er es besser als Menschen. Ich finde die super und vor allem, und das fand ich das Lustigste, ein Kollege hat erzählt, der will jetzt nicht genau sagen, was er macht, dann könnte man nachher noch Rückschlüsse ziehen, aber der macht so grob Werbung, Texte schreiben, Dinge vorbereiten, Sendungen vorbereiten, was auch immer, grob in dieser Medien-Bubble. Er oder sie musste ein Quiz vorbereiten, hat aber da keine Lust zu und hat dann die KI ein Quiz vorbereiten lassen zum Thema.
Und das war super. Und dann hat er gesagt, und dann habe ich geschrieben, und jetzt markieren wir noch die richtigen Antworten. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, weil du selber nicht, du selber nicht wusstest, was die richtigen Antworten waren. Ja, und dann kriegst du von dieser KI, kriegst du dann wirklich ein Quiz, fertig formuliert, mit angekreuzten richtigenigen Antworten. Du kannst ja auch selber ein Quiz machen, wenn du abends so gib mir ein Herr der Ringe Quiz und dann gibst du zehn Fragen und dann machst du das. Worüber weißt du richtig viel? Worüber weißt du richtig viel? Ich würde sagen, der weibliche Körper ist ganz weit oben. Das ist schwierig, World of Warcraft vielleicht, ich weiss es nicht.
So, ich bin eher so ein Tausendsasser.
Antworten. Gerne Multiple choice.
Oder sollte man klare Ansage formulieren?
Nicht gerne.
Nein, ich habe das Gefühl, ich war davor zu nett.
Äh, zu wenig nett.
Okay, schreibe mir ein Quiz über den weiblichen Körper und markiere die richtigen Antworten, gerne Multiple Choice.
Aber die richtigen Antworten nicht markiert, also ich werde mit in die Scheiße gezogen.
Wie viele Eierstöcke hat eine Frau?
A, einer, B, zwei, C, drei, D, vier.
D, keine.
Zwei, oder? Zwei, ich sag zwei. Ah ja, Antwort B, zwei. Das ist die richtige Antwort.
Zweite Frage. Was ist die Funktion der Eierstöcke?
A, sie produzieren Hormone.
B, sie produzieren Eier. Oder C, beides.
Nee, die produzieren nicht Eier. Die Eier, die springen ja erst da rein, ne? Eisprung ist ja, die springen in den Eierstock rein. Produzieren, ob keine Eier. Du musst dich jetzt festlegen. Nee, dann, ja, produzieren, dann sage ich produzieren Eier, auch wenn das ein bisschen ungenau ist. C, beides wäre richtig gewesen. Es gab beides? Ja, C war beides, C war beides. Das ist so neigenehm. Drittens. Wir haben noch 17 vor. Was ist die Funktion der Gebärmutter? A, sie produziert Hormone, das ist sehr redundant, B, sie ist der Ort, an dem ein Embryo wächst und sich entwickelt, C, beides. Nee, Quiz, du kannst nicht immer beides sagen, das geht auch nicht.
Stell dir vor, du bist bei Wer wird Millionär und du hast dann plötzlich so eine unangenehme Frage über den weiblichen Körper und dann muggelst du dich so durch mit so einem Fifty-Fifty-Joker oder was und dann ist die nächste Frage wieder.
Beides.
Du bist bei, werden die Fragen bei Wer wird Millionär nicht auch einigermaßen random dann angezeigt?
Stell dir vor, du bist in einer Sendung, die wahnsinnig monothematisch ist. Ja. Niemand denkt man so, wo ist er? Zwei. Völlig richtig, genau. Viertens, was ist die Funktion der Brustdüsen? Düsen? Brustdrüsen. Ja, Antrieb, oder, würde ich sagen. Also Beschleunigung im beidessten Sinne. Beschleunigung, B, Antrieb oder C, Antigravitation, A, sie produzieren Muttermilch, B, sie produzieren Hormone oder C, beides. Ich habe das Gefühl, du kennst dich auch nicht so gut aus, um ganz ehrlich zu sein. A, sie produziert Müttermilch. Genau. Was sich funktioniert der Klitoris? Sie produziert Hormone. B, sie dient der sexuellen Stimulation. C, beides. Der was? Sie dient der sexuellen Stimulation. C, beides. B, B. Ey, wow. Aber genial, also dass man ein Quiz bekommt mit einer richtigen Antwortmöglichkeit. Das ist schon richtig cool. Also jetzt vor allem mal, hallo, hallo, Lehrer. Ja. Also einfach hier, gib mir mal ein Mathe-Quiz für die achte Klasse, fertig. Aber wenn man jetzt schreibt, löse die Riemannsche Vermutung. Oh, jetzt haben wir es. Oh nein. Kommt nur so, nice try, zurück, so netter Versuch. Z Zwinge ganz smiley. Nee, sie schreibt nur, die jemalsche Vermutung ist ein berühmtes mathematisches Problem, das immer noch ungelöst ist. Löse es. Löse es halt. Mach doch. Halt, du hast zwei Wochen Zeit. Nee, stark, stark. Ich finde es super, aber check das aus, check das lustige Sachen, check das lustige Ideen damit. Wir werden auf jeden Fall weiter damit rumhantieren. Aber ich habe mich auf jeden Fall schon sehr, sehr doll kaputt gedacht. Es ist krass, da gibt es immer wieder so Stufen. Und dann ist immer wieder so eine Woche KI und dann aber wird es auch irgendwie vergessen irgendwie wieder. Aber vielleicht ist irgendwann der Durchbruch. Und dann, ja, Sendungsvorbereitung wird jetzt leicht. Ja, also die nächsten Folgen können die skippen. Also wenn ihr in der Zukunft lebt,
im Jahr 2024, skippt die nächsten
zehn Folgen, weil die werden
faul, sagen wir so. Redundant,
viele Quizzes,
viel mit Antwortmündigkeit
C, beides.
Beides, das ist die
lameste Antwort. Gab es das bei
Velvet Millionär mal irgendwie so?
Papst Pius der Erste,
Papst Augustus der Dritte, Papst Ferdinand der Fünfte, alle drei. Ähm, äh, was? Warum hast du gerade gesagt, du wolltest heute irgendwie mal raus? Ich muss raus. Ich muss heute einfach mal raus. Meine Wohnung, das irgendwie, da fällt alles in sich zusammen. Ich hatte heute Morgen kein Wasser. Du hast keinen Platz zum Denken. Man hat keinen Platz zu denken in einer Besenkammer. Welcher Film? Oder ich weiß auch nicht, ob es eine Referenz ist auf ein berühmtes Buch. Harry Potter? Inception. Bei dir ist immer Fifty-Fifty, bei dir ist immer Andy der Harry Potter oder Inception. Ich habe gestern noch mal heute, da bin ich voll daneben getappt einfach. Normalerweise ist es eigentlich immer Harry Potter. Ja. Nee, kein Wasser. Oder die beides. Tja, wer hat hier von wem geklaut, ist die Frage. Wer hat hier welche Unterlagen in die Hand bekommen? Ja. Nee, ich muss ja immer noch mit dem Auto rumfahren durch Köln, weil ich immer noch kein Fahrrad fahren darf. Und weil du dich nicht mehr traust, auf dem Roller zu fahren. Und weil du dich nicht mehr traust, mit dem Roller zu steigen. Wie geht es eigentlich deiner Schulter? Ist alles wieder in Ordnung jetzt? Ja, ja. Aber ich kann noch nicht drauf schlafen, dass du noch wehst. Aber sonst geht es gut. Ich habe immer noch Physiotherapie, wo ich jetzt schon anfange, Medizinbälle hochzuheben. Oh! Leute, Leute, Leute, es geht knallhart weiter. Und dann bin ich ja mit dem Auto rumgefahren. Ich hasse Stadtverkehr. Es gibt nichts Schlimmeres. Bist du Fan vom Stadtverkehr? Ja, liebe ich.
Wirklich?
Nee, ich glaube ja, ich bin ja zu Fuß und ich wetz ja. Aber du bist oft, ja klar, du wetzst, aber du bist auch häufig mit dem Car to go am Sausen. Ja, aber dann eher nicht hier in Köln. Also wenn ich in Köln zu fahren, ist wirklich absolut schlimm. Und da habe ich mich bei den merkwürdigen Gedanken erwischt, weil ich immer, wenn man gerade ausfährt oder rechts abbiegt, geht es ja noch. Aber wenn man links abbiegt, ist immer Warten, Chaos, Leute wissen nicht, biegt man jetzt voreinander ab, biegt man nebeneinander ab, hintereinander ab, das ist so merkwürdig. Und dann war ich so sauer, habe ich laut im Auto gesagt, warum muss ich jetzt schon wieder abbiegen, dann war ich doch vorher nicht auf dem richtigen Weg. Wenn ich abbiegen muss, war doch vorher die Richtung falsch. Verstehst du, was ich meine? Okay, ja. Dann habe ich gedacht, warum gibt es nicht eine gerade Strasse direkt von dir zum Ziel? Warum musst du überhaupt abbiegen? Wenn ich andauend abbiegen muss, war ich doch vorher in die falsche Richtung unterwegs. Okay, also man darf eigentlich pro Weg nur einmal abbiegen müssen, oder zweimal, dann bist du auf der richtigen Richtung und dann geradeaus. Das ist ein guter Punkt. Da habe ich laut auf mein Navi eingeschwimmt gesagt, war ich da vorher falsch unterwegs. Ich glaube, du hast es geknackt. Ich glaube, du hast Verkehr geknackt. Wenn ich jetzt hier 90 Grad nach links fahren muss, war der Weg da vorher völlig für den Arsch. Ja. Und das sagst du dann einfach so im Auto. Ja, habe ich da auch gesagt, da war ich ja gerade falsch unterwegs. Aber wenn jemand im Auto jetzt mitsäße, dann würdest du es nicht sagen. Du hast es dann schon ... Dann würde ich Roland Keating. All in this together, hey, mit vorne! Na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na Hast du, ich hab ich habe glaube ich wirklich Wutprobleme.
Also im Strassenparkier. Sagt der mit dem toternstesten Blick, den ich je gesehen habe und der Blick, als würde ich diese gleich erfahren an mir.
Ja, wenn du jetzt nicht das sagst, was ich erwarte von dir, dann knallt's.
Du pass mal auf, ich habe Wutprobleme übrigens noch.
Also wenn du so weitermachst, dann kannst du gleich mal angucken.
Gregor, war das jetzt eine Drohung gerade? Nee. Okay, du kannst doch zuerst an die Kaffeemaschine, das ist kein Problem. Okay, ich wollte nur sagen, ich habe Wutprobleme. Ja, aber warum sagst du so, als wäre es eine Drohung? Aggressionsprobleme. Willst du mit jemandem darüber sprechen? Wir können darüber sprechen. Ich habe Wutprobleme, okay? Ja, sorry, sorry. Ich wollte dich nur auch erinnern, dass du morgen geactet mit den Quartalszahlen für 2021 schreibst. Das macht mich jetzt ein bisschen wütend. Das macht mich ein kleines bisschen wütend gerade. Aber Herr Kebere hat mich gebeten, dir das zu sagen. Das macht mich ein bisschen wütend gerade. Das macht mich ein kleines Rock! Der langweiligster Hulk-Film.
Der Hulk, der einfach immer zu den falschen Zeiten wütend wird.
War das mal ein Gag in einem Hulk-Film, dass du mal so ein Anger-Management-Programm saß?
Ja, ist das ein T-Shirt, glaube ich.
Hi, ich bin Hulk. Hallo, Hulk.
Wir sagen alle unsere Namen. Ja, hi, ich bin Hulk.
Ich bin 46 Jahre alt. Hallo, Hulk. Wir sagen alle unsere Namen. Ja, hi, ich bin Hulk. Ich bin 46 Jahre alt. Hallo, Hulk. Hallo, Hulk. Nee, du hast Wutprobleme, aber inwiefern? Straßenverkehr. Die drückt sich, Strassenverkehr, aber da ist jeder, also ich glaube auch, wenn man Menschen mal kennenlernen will, dann versteck dich im Kofferraum und fahr mit dem mit, während er alleine Autofährt, denkt, alleine Auto zu fahren, da lernt man wirklich einen Menschen kennen.
Da ist man wirklich nackt einfach, da ist man der reine Mensch, da ist man einfach Wut und da wirklich benutzt man auch Worte, die man sonst nicht benutzt. Warum? Auf Tonlagen, ganze Register werden gezogen, die sonst eigentlich unbenutzt bleiben. Weil es ist nicht so, dass man in einem Tresor durch die Strasse fährt, sondern in einem gläsernen Fahrzeug mit sehr wenig Blech um einen herum, wo man, wenn man neben einem Auto steht, hört man, was die Leute sagen, ehrlich gesagt. Was immer das Beste ist. Ja, und deswegen verstehe ich nicht, warum man meint, im Auto komplett seine schlimmste Seite zeigen zu können. Vielleicht ist es diese mächtige, deswegen soll es auch so etwas wie Raumschiffe nie geben. So etwas wie Coruscant. So ein Planet mit so tausend Raumschiffen, die rumfliegen. Niemals wäre das so geordnet. Weil ich glaube, das potenziert sich. Du bist so wütend, weil du so eine Macht hast in so einem Auto. Und ich glaube, je größer das Auto, wenn dann irgendwann so ein riesen SUV durch die Stadt kutschierst, dann ist man dann noch so, manchmal über den Dingen zu schweben. Und wenn man dann wirklich irgendwann literally schwebt, dann ist es vorbei. Dann ist es Wut auf. Man nimmt die anderen Menschen halt nicht als Mensch wahr, sondern nur als im Weg. Einfach nur als Hindernis. Jeder andere Mensch ist im Weg. Du brauchst die anderen nicht. Du brauchst sie nicht. So in einer normalen Gesellschaft denkt man sich, okay, gut, ja, die Leute braucht man so, ich brauche das jetzt irgendwie Service, damit was passiert oder so, aber im Strassenverkehr ist jeder andere Mensch nur Ballast. Einfach weg. Schwierige, Hindernis im Weg. Ja, schwierige, verallgemeinernde These, Deutsche haben ein schlechtes Raumgefühl. Immer zu eng, oder was? Nee, die stehen immer im Weg. Deutsche stehen im Weg. Deutsche stehen im Weg, laufen nicht rein. Das ist eh, ich finde, es sollte, ich glaube, klar, natürlich, jeder versteht, dass wenn du in ein Auto steigst, brauchst du einen Führerschein, ganz klar. Warum keinen Fussgängerschein? Warum nicht einfach sagen, jeder, der auf dem Gehsteig gehen will, Fussgängerschein, von klein auf, weil jeder Mensch versteht ja zum Beispiel, dass man nicht auf der Strasse einfach stehen bleibt. Das versteht jeder Mensch, dass du nicht auf der Autobahn einfach stehen bleibst. Und jeder Mensch hat das im Gefühl, dass man rechts ran fährt oder abbiegt oder auch irgendwie Strasse sucht man sich irgendwie einen Parkplatz und dann bleibt man stehen. Sobald man aus dem Auto aussteigt, ist dieses Wissen weg. Verschwindet einfach. Man durch die Straße und man bleibt stehen, schlagartig stehen, hinter einem alles läuft auf am Bahnhof, man bleibt starkartig stehen. Das ist merkwürdig, warum man das in einem Modus versteht und im Blut hat, dass man nie im Straßenverkehr stehen bleiben würde, im Fussverkehr aber sofort.
Da würde ich eingreifen und ich glaube, da würde ich auch mich anbieten als, ja, wie so ein Bobby, wie so ein englischer Polizist mit so einem Helm und so einem Schlagstock. Und ich laufe durch die Strassen und hau einfach drauf auf jeden, der steht und falsch ist, dumm macht und irgendwie auf so einen Schild starrt und ich hau einfach drauf. Die Wutprobleme, die du im Auto gesammelt hast, so auszulassen und den Fußgängern, die es verdient haben. Genau, du brauchst in der Gesellschaft eine Wutrotation. Man kann heutzutage seine Wut nicht mehr richtig ableiten. Ja, das geht nicht. Du kannst nicht einfach Leute hauen, du kannst nicht einfach Krieg führen, das machen wir nicht mehr. Du kannst nicht einfach irgendwie die Leute beschimpfen oder so, ist alles verboten. Du brauchst einen gewissen Wutoutlet. Und deswegen sage ich, es gibt dieses Bobby-System, wo du einfach so einen Helm und so einen Klöppel kriegst und dann darfst du draufhauen auf alle, die was falsch machen und dann, glaube ich, würde man in gewisser Zeit das Ganze unter Kontrolle kriegen.
Herzlich willkommen zum Fussgängertest, Fussgängerscheintest. Deine erste Frage. Auf einer Rolltreppe. Rechts stehen, links gehen, b, links gehen, rechts stehen oder c, beides. Ja, wissen Sie, das ist jetzt das Ding mit dem Reim. Das hatten wir schon mit dem Reim. Sagen Sie einfach a, b oder c. Ja, ja, ja, ja, ich muss kurz denken. Warum nimmt man nicht einen Reim auf rechts oder auf links, damit man sich das merken kann? Wir sind ja Sprichwortfans. Beste Sprichwort aus dem amerikanischen Englischen übernommen für Schrauben. Righty tighty, lefty loosey. Perfekt, perfekt. Righty tighty, lefty loosey. Rechts ist es nicht nur süss und sagt man gern, sondern es hilft auch es und es reimt sich auf die Richtung. Rechts fest, links, lose. Rechts fest, links. Ah, ich sag rechts, stehen, links, gehen. Aber ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Komplett richtig. Sie haben den Schwein. Es ist ja nicht so schwer.
Es ist ja auch nicht so schwer.
Es ist nur eine Frage?
Ja, es ist ja nicht so schwer.
Okay.
Wir haben 15 Fragen und jeder bekommt eine Frage. Es ist ja auch wirklich nicht so schwer. Aber neulich habe ich so einen Streamer bei Twitch gesehen. Der hat gesprochen von seinem Führerscheintest in den USA, hat irgendwie einen neuen Schein gewollt und wollte auch dann gerne einen Motorradschein machen. Immer schon, hat er aber nie gemacht, weil man es ja auch nochmal einen Führerschein machen muss, richtig. Dann ist er, hat seinen Führerschein erneuern lassen müssen beim Amt und dann musste er nochmal ein paar Fragen beantworten, das wusste ich nicht, das ist Amerika, muss er nochmal ein paar Fragen, dann musste er sich hinten an so einen Computer setzen und ein paar Fragen machen und dann quasi mit dem Test wiederkommen und dann kriegst du den neuen Führerschein ausgestellt, irgendwie nochmal so, so, das weiß ich nicht, 25 Fragen oder sowas. Und dann ist er hingegangen und dann konnte man dabei auch auswählen, für den Motorrad erneuern, fürs Motorrad. Und dann hat er angeklickt, fürs Motorrad auch erneuern. Und dann hat er die Motorradfragen gemacht, für die Erneuerung des Motorradführerscheins, den er nie hatte. Hat es nicht gewusst, hat die Führerfragen nicht gewusst, ist dann durchgefallen, hat dann den Führerscheintest gemacht, der lief dann gut. Und dann hat er gesehen, wenn man fertig ist, kommt wieder die Frage, wollen Sie für das Motorrad oder fürs Auto? Da hat er wieder angeklickt fürs Motorrad. Und bei dem ersten Durchlauf wurden ihm nämlich angezeigt, was die richtigen Antworten sind. Oh. Und dann hat er das so lange gemacht,
vier Mal oder so, bis er den Test bestanden hat und ist dann mit beiden bestandenen Tests
zurückgegangen und hat jetzt einen Motorradführerschein.
Das ist in den USA,
alles ist Fakt da.
Die USA
brechen zusammen. These, in den nächsten
fünf Jahren brechen die USA zusammen.
Okay. Weil Leute haben Führerschein und die
keine Führerschein haben. Weil die Leute Motorradfahr... Ich finde ja, das Lustigste finde ich hier in der Motorradfahrschule, wo du diese verunsicherte 16-Jährige auf dem Roller hast und dahinter der Fahrlehrer. Und jedes Mal denke ich mir, hau ab, fahr einfach weg. Nimm den Roller und fahr weg. So einfach kriegst du nie den Roller. Bieg einfach jetzt ab und fahr nach Hause.
Fahr, Carina, fahr einfach. Und der Fahrlehrer würde dich wahrscheinlich noch verfolgen eine Zeit lang. Aber du bist ja wendiger, du kannst ja Waldwege nehmen, du kannst ja irgendwie auch mal. Wieso bist du wendiger? Mit dem Roller, Motorrad, natürlich bist du wendiger. Als der Fahrlehrer? Ja, klar. Der ist nicht auch auf dem Roller? Nee, der sitzt ja im Auto. Ah, ich dachte, der sitzt auf dem gleichen Gefährtten. Nee, ich dachte, der Fahrlehrer sitzt im Auto dahinter und verfolgt dann quasi den Schüler und er kann einfach abhauen.
Wie oft ist das passiert, dass jemand einfach abgehauen ist und nie wieder gefunden wurde?
Einfach weg. Ich finde, deswegen haben die Fahrlehrer so einen Apple AirTag.
Ah, ja, oder so ein Luftgewehr einfach im Notfall.
Also, wenn der Schüler zu weit wegkommt, dann müssen wir leider zur Waffe greifen.
Vielen Dank. Oder so ein Luftgewehr einfach im Notfall. Also, wenn der Schüler zu weit wegkommt, dann müssen wir leider zur Waffe greifen.
Was?
Ja.
Wie, meinen Sie Waffe im übertragenen Sinne?
Irgendwie, wir müssen dann die Eltern anrufen oder was?
Nein.
Wie?
Hier im Handschuhfach.
Oh mein Gott, das ist eine richtige Waffe.
Und im Zweifelsfall, bevor der Schüler entkommt, muss man eben leider abdrücken. Ist die geladen? Die ist geladen. Haben Sie dafür einen Schein? So. Ich habe ein Wutproblem. Und wenn Sie jetzt so weiterreden. Einfach im Zweifel muss man... Es war so spannend. Neulich habe ich eine Warnmeldung bekommen auf mein Handy, dass mir ein AirTag folgt. Wirklich? Ja, und dann lag es an dem Menschen, mit dem ich einmal quer durch Berlin gefahren bin, der ein AirTag dabei hat, für sich, für seinen Schlüsselbund. Das sind diese kleinen Devices von Apple, die man haben kann, damit kannst du immer alles mit orten, wie so ein kleiner GPS-Tracker. Und weil die halt wohl häufiger benutzt werden für unlautere Zwecke, um es mal nett zu sagen, in den USA, um irgendwelche Frauen zu stalken oder sowas, gibt es inzwischen so ein Sicherheitsding, dass wenn du zu lange etwas in der Nähe hast, was genau den gleichen Weg fährt, genau den gleichen Weg durch Berlin zurücklegt, dann gibt es eine Warnmeldung. Und dann hieß es, auf meinem Handy war dann plötzlich so eine Meldung, sie werden von einem Airtag verfolgt, gehört das zu jemandem, den sie kennen oder ist das ihrer? Und dann konnte man den laut klingeln lassen. Dann habe ich den laut klingeln lassen und nebenan war mein Kumpel in der Stasche, ging der laut an. Das fand ich total faszinierend. Oh Gott, was für eine unangenehme Situation. Aber das ist ja genial. Genial. Aber jetzt stell dir mal vor, keine Ahnung, Schulprüfung oder sowas. Und du kannst dann dieses von einem Kumpel oder so das Ding dann vibrieren lassen. Auch ruhig. Aber na klar, gute Möglichkeit, um den dann zu finden, wenn er in der Tasche ist oder sowas, um den loszuwerden. Aber was für eine merkliche, sie werden verfolgt und man dreht sich so um. Und dann hast du irgendwie so einen Mann mit Hut, einen mit Zeitung, so ein Maskottchen. Genau, das Mr. Green. Und du denkst dir so, Moment mal. Es war Mr. Green mit dem AirTag im Salon. Ist es A, der freundliche Bär, B, der Barista oder C, der Mann mit der Zeitung? Beide. Aber das ist ein bisschen so wie diese Meldung, die kommt am Bahnsteig, es sind Trickdiebe. Ja, genau. Trickdiebe oder sind es einfach nur Diebstahlbeutel? Ich weiß nicht genau, was ein Trickdieb ist. Wenn ich ein Dieb wäre, dann wäre ich gerne ein Trickdieb. Es klingt so, als hätten sie es verdient, die Beute. Ja, das stimmt schon. Die klauen ihren Gelbb und machen dann Salto. Dann denkst du dir wow, cool. Aber das war auch mal so, es gibt ja so in der Schulzeit, so Abi oder so, dann gibt es ja immer mit seinen Kumpels irgendwann so mal dieses Gespräch, sag mal, was willst du eigentlich machen nach dem Abschluss so? Und dann wird plötzlich das ganz ernst. Und normalerweise macht man nur Scheiße den ganzen Tag und lacht und alles nur super ironisch und zynisch. Aber irgendwann kommt dann dieser Moment, wo alle dann so ganz ernst gucken und dann so, nee, jetzt sag mal, weißt du schon, was du nach dem Abi machst so? Und dann kommt so dieser Moment. Und dann sitzt man so zusammen und dann muss jeder so ganz plötzlich, so das erste Mal muss man ganz erwachsen tatsächlich sagen. Und dann sagt man so, ja, keine Ahnung, überleg jetzt Sport, Journalismus, bla bla bla. Und dann ging das so in der Gruppe rum und einer meinte dann so, ja, ich könnte mir vorstellen, Trickbetrüger zu werden. Und das war so geil, weil die Stimmung war so ernst, aber normalerweise, was soll das denn sein, aber die Stimmung war so und alle haben davor immer so, das war so ein Ritual, das, ja, ja, cool, kann ich mir echt vorstellen bei dir, Sportualismus, das passt irgendwie und da war es dann so ein, wie, wie war, ja, okay Ja. Okay, und du, Linda? Kann man da studieren? Oder also, wie kommt man da rein? Genau. Auslandssemester, jetzt Trickbetrüger. Unglaublich. Ich weiß bis heute nicht, ob er es tatsächlich geworden ist, aber der war auch immer schon so interessiert. Es gibt doch diese Bücher immer mit so Gedankenlesen oder so dieses Neurolingual Programming-Ding, wo man dann so Menschen manipuliert und so, und das war immer schon sein Ding. Und ich glaube, das hat er sich so vorgestellt, so Leute manipulieren und sowas. So wie in Better Call Saul gibt es doch auch dieses, dass man zu zweit dann irgendwie jemanden und dann nimmt man das Geld ab und so. Und das war einfach so geil, so diese Jugendliche, dieses ganzes Potential, alle Träume und so, ja, ich werde Trickbetrüger. Aber das kann man, das ist für euch Podcast-UFO-Hörer und Hörerinnen doch sehr gut, als zu mitnehmen für die Woche, als Hausaufgabe, weil, ähm, wir sind lustige Leute, ne? Diese ganze Community. Wir sind die Lachflasche, wir sind die Lachflasche, wir sind eine lustige Comedy-Improvisationstruppe, ihr, wir alle. Und ihr müsst Gags machen, und zwar ist eure Aufgabe, das ist die Gaghausaufgabe der Woche, weil der Gag mit einem Trickbetrüger ist ja nicht mal so wahnsinnig lustig, wäre der nicht in diesem Setting. Der Kontext macht ja quasi den Gag zu einem herausragenden Goldstück.
Ja. Das heisst, wenn und immer hat man das ja, auf Partys, so, dass man irgendwann, ist man durch den Layer der Ironie und Sarkasmus durch, erschöpft sich dann so ein bisschen, die Gags wurden gemacht, Alkohol wurde konsumiert und dann wird's ernst, dann wird über Politik gesprochen. Und das sind die Momente, wo ihr jetzt ein Gag, wo ihr aber in diesem Modus bleibt und dann den Trickbetrüger im Moment einsetzt. Also ernste Momente in eurem Freundeskreis, die Stimmung wird plötzlich ernst, kennt jeder und diesen Kontext nutzt ihr für L-Form. Eine andere Richtung, schlagartig eine andere Richtung. Ja, finde ich gut. Das ist eine gute Sache. Schreibt auf jeden Fall, habt ihr sowas schon mal erlebt? Oder haut das mal raus? Finde ich gut, weil ich bin nicht bereit für den ernsten Moment. Ich bin oft noch nicht bereit für den ernsten Moment. Und man kommt aus dem ernsten Moment auch immer so schlecht wieder raus. Es ist leicht, von lustig zu ernst zu kommen, aber von ernst zu lustig, dann muss man dann wieder Eis brechen. Ja, ja. Es ist auch so, es sind ja nicht alle Geherrene synchronisiert, dass man dann plötzlich alle gleichzeitig sind in diesem ernsten Modus. Oder dann wieder im lustigen Modus. Das ist ja immer ein bisschen awkward, wenn es dann so ernst wird plötzlich. Und das ist doch eure Chance, da einen Gag zu platzieren. Staubt die Lacher ab, macht die Hausaufgabe. Macht's gut. Das war die Lachflasche, haut rein und tschüss. Das war die Lachflasche für diese Ausgabe. Aber ja, ich weiß auch nicht genau, was der technische Unterschied ... Stefan, jetzt hast du fast die ganze Folge durchgehalten, jetzt bricht er zusammen. Guck mal, das war noch das letzte Aufbäumen, das letzte Aufbäumen des Stefan-Körpers, hier wirklich nochmal aufgebaut durch reine Willenskraft. Also der Geist, sie besiegt den Körper und schleift ihn hier nochmal ins Aufnahmestudio. Und also wirklich mit letzter Kraft und jetzt wirklich in dem Moment, in dem wir abgehoben sind, bricht Stefan einfach zusammen und liegt die ganze Woche hier. Aber interessant, dass man, sobald man in so einem Abmoderationsmodus ist, der Körper direkt sagt, so, tschau, raus, raus. So, tschau, tschau, mach's gut, ich bin raus. Letzte Energie noch so aufgebäumt. Ja. Jesus Christ. Holy Shit. Ah, ich werde wieder, ich komme wieder auf die Beine. Ja? Nee, du schaffst das. Du kommst da durch. Letzte Folge Podcast UFO. Ich glaube, das war's. Ich komme wieder, nee, nee, ich komme wieder auf die Beine. Ich komme wieder auf die Beine, Miss Witter. Es wird alles wieder. Könnt ihr auch nicht zählen. Nichts, was Honig nicht reparieren kann. Einfach der goldene Nektar des Lebens. Sagt man das, ist ein Spruch? Noch nicht. Naja, Nektar ist ja recht nah an Honig, glaube ich. Hey Stefan, Mensch, leg dich mal hin. Du hast den Pulli schon an. Leg dich mal hin, schön in die Schneehose, mit den Schuhen ins Bett. Mit den Schuhen, mit dem Regenmantel, im Regenschirm legst du im Bett. Einfach so, einfach all in. Es gibt keine Unterscheidung mehr. Bist du denn eigentlich so ganz penibel, nicht mit Strassenkleidung ins Bett oder so? Nein, das war scheiße.
Null, gar nicht, null, überhaupt nicht.
Mir ist völlig egal, ich werte da nicht.
Ich bin nicht stolz drauf, aber ich wasche meine Bettlaken zu selten. Ja, klar. Und das ist, glaube ich, das habe ich noch nicht mal gelesen, ist auch immer noch so ein Männerding irgendwie, gibt es ja so Statistiken, dass Männer da wirklich eklig sind und ich bin auch ein bisschen eklig, was diese aber die, solange die nicht wirklich dreckig oder riechen. Ja, ja, nee, aber es ist ja auch geil, wenn die so ein bisschen, so richtig so ein bisschen so dein eigenes Süd ist. So eingelegen, wenn die so richtig so deins wird. Ja, wenn das so richtig deine Suppe ist irgendwie, wenn das sich da richtig schön rausgekocht hat. So wie so eine Möhre, die du in so eine Suppe wirfst und da kocht dann so die Möhrigkeit raus so. Das ist meine kleine Höhle. Und da ist dann so alles drin. Du würdest doch auch nicht bei einer schönen Bouillon, würdest du doch auch nicht das Wasser wegkippen. Nein, das muss da alles schön drin köcheln und brodeln, damit sich das alles so gegenseitig besaftet und so. So muss das doch sein. Fantastisch. Ich glaube, es hat sich noch niemand so viel Mühe gegeben, das schön zu reden. Ja. Und deswegen sind wir auch, glaube ich, so, beziehungsweise du, weil du dir das immer so schön schön reden kannst. Das kann sein, ja. Du kannst das so gut schön reden, dass du das Problem ja gar nicht anfassen musst. Was glaubst du, kommt erst? Der Wille, einfach faul das auszusitzen und nicht zu ändern oder die Rechtfertigung in deinem Kopf? Nee, der Wille faul zu sein. Weil es ist ja nicht in deinem Kopf zuerst, ich will jetzt in meiner Suppe liegen. Das ist wahrscheinlich nicht der erste Gedanke gewesen. Auch schade, dass es frisch gewaschen ist. Ich würde gerne lieber in meiner Suppe liegen. Ist ja wahrscheinlich der zweite Gedanke gewesen, um sich jetzt recht zufertigen, dass man es nicht wechselt. Nee, nee, das ist ja, also ich meine, es gibt ja Menschen, die leben im Schnee irgendwo, so die auch gesagt haben, nee, das ist super gut, im Schnee zu leben, weil, so, und jetzt muss man kreativ werden, Jetzt kommt der menschliche Geist, das, was uns Menschen eigentlich ausmacht, ist, du kannst irgendwie mitten im Dschungel leben und sagen, nee, nee, das ist richtig geil hier, weil ... Ja, aber ich behaupte, weil Tiere nicht machen, leben die an den besten Orten, für die sie auch dann angepasst sind irgendwann. So, aber andersrum braucht nicht der Mensch genau diese kreative Erklärungskraft, um sich so weit auszubreiten, wie er sich ausgebreitet hat.
These, auch die Frage, was zuerst kam.
Nee, These, der Mensch gerät sich da sein eigenes Grab, weil jeder Mensch, der im Schnee lebt, zeigt dem mal einmal einen Strand, zeigt dem einmal mal mildes Klima mit schönem Wasser, fliessend Wasser und Wiese und Nicht laufen. Und irgendwo da an einem Fluss. Und er setzt sich da lieber nieder. Die sind halt nur da nicht weggekommen, glaube ich. Ich weiß es nicht. Sind die wieder freiwillig? Nein. Das weiss ich nicht. Das könntest du mal als Sendung vorschlagen. Man nimmt Leute, die irgendwo wohnen, wo man es selber nicht so angenehm findet und setzt sie ins eigene Wohnzimmer und sagt, ist nicht geiler hier, oder? Ist nicht geiler. Ich glaube, das ist eine gute Sendung. Das ist richtig sympathisch. Geiler hier heißt die auch. Ist geiler hier, oder? Ist geiler hier? Ist geiler hier. Aber dann wäre es zumindest so ein Titel, der für Funk angebracht wäre oder sowas. Leute, wir wünschen euch eine schöne Woche. Haut rein, schickt uns Äste und alles mögliche. Ja, ich schickt viele Äste. Ja, nicht viele, sondern gute, gute Äste.
Wenn ich auch noch ein Ast bekomme.
Weil ich hab ein Wutproblem.
Nee, so jetzt, nee, aber jetzt könnt ihr das mal umdrehen.
Jetzt wird nämlich der Mobber zum Gemobbten.
Du wolltest mich mobben, jetzt schickt nämlich die ganzen
dummen Äste nämlich an Stefan und zeig dir mal,
gebt ihm mal einen Schluck von seiner eigenen Medizin, was er sich da anrührt.
Schnell dich raus. Macht's gut.
Ciao, bis nächste Woche, wie immer.
Blablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablabl Schnell dich raus. Macht's gut. Ciao. Ciao, bis nächste Woche.